[Musica]
a palermo c'è il fiume oreto un fiume
bellissimo con una storia molto antica
che negli ultimi anni è stato oggetto di
diverse problematiche a livello
ambientale in questo punto della città
proprio il fiume traccia un confine
finisce il centro storico ed inizia la
periferia sulla foce del fiume in questo
punto nasce e sorge da alcuni anni un
nuovo museo
l'ecomuseo urbano mare memoria viva e
una di quelle istituzioni che a noi
piace chiamare istituzione commovente è
un luogo dedicato alle persone al
prendersi cura delle persone del
territorio e in particolare dell'acqua
sia nella costa sia sul fiume e qui dal
30 di aprile 2021 che sorge una nuova
opera d'arte è una piccola pianta una
pianta artificiale che emette suoni e
luci ed è il progetto latinos
ecco questa piantina fa una cosa
abbastanza straordinaria perché se vi
avvicinate sentireste che emette delle
dei suoni e delle luci questi suoni e
queste luci permettono di comprendere e
conoscere lo stato di salute del fiume
che sta a pochi passi tra l'altro
pensate che meraviglia un fenomeno così
complesso come lo stato di salute di un
intero fiume espresso in modo
comprensibile e facile da interpretare
tanto che anche un bambino può
conoscere e sapere come sta il fiume
sele luci sono sull'azzurro il fiume è
in salute se le luci danno tonalità che
vanno verso il rosso
beh vuol dire che c'è qualche problema
nell'ecosistema se i suoni sono limpidi
e cristallini e vuol dire che l'acqua è
pulita come il suono se invece i suoni
sono sporchi con del rumore
allora vuol dire che anche l'acqua è
sporca vedete è una cosa semplicissima
che anche un bambino può interpretare
questa piantina digitale una scultura
elettronica tra l'altro ispirata alle
piantine che crescono veramente lungo il
fiume è uno dei risultati del progetto u
dati non sono come ha detto oriana che è
un progetto che per la l'anno scorso
interamente ha unito il nostro centro di
ricerca hershey loss data insieme all
eco un museo mare memoria viva ed è
stato sostenuto e promosso dal programma
creative living laps del ministero della
cultura per raccogliere dati e
alimentare la nostra piantina avremmo
potuto scegliere una strada molto
semplice per esempio dislocare dei
sensori lungo il corso del fiume ma
abbiamo scelto una strada molto diversa
abbiamo deciso di creare un nuovo ruolo
sociale insieme alle commisero urbano
mare memoria viva e insieme a tutti i
cittadini
abbiamo inventato i custodi dell'acqua
un gruppo di cittadini erano 15 fra
studenti ricercatori attivisti del patto
di fiume e di costa che già si prende
cura del fiume e che hanno partecipato a
due work
molto semplici e nei quali hanno
ottenuto da un lato delle semplici
tecnologie un 7 di sensori che ancora
una volta anche dei bambini possono
utilizzare e dall'altro lato sia la
conoscenza sia la sensibilità per andare
a raccogliere i dati sul fiume e a
capire lo stato di benessere delle acque
ecco una nuova ritualità era nata
proprio come negli antichi tempi si
andava a raccogliere l'acqua al fiume o
lavare i panni bene i custodi dell'acqua
vanno lì a generare i dati per avere una
nuova sensibilità e soprattutto
condividerla con gli altri perché ci
trasferiscono la possibilità anche a noi
anche a chi guarderà alla piantina
all'interno del museo di diventare un po
più sensibili a un fenomeno così
complesso come la salute del di un
intero fiume questa tecnologia questa
nostra piantina non solo vive delle
relazioni che riesce a stabilire e della
cura dei custodi dell'acqua ma proprio
come noi è un vero e proprio organismo
vivo nonostante sia fatta di ricavi e
sia un essere artificiale esposta alla
vulnerabilità
se i custodi vecchi e nuovi non
alimentano non innaffiano questa
piantina con nuovi dati proprio come una
piantina vegetale lei tenderà a
spegnersi e ce lo mostrerà proprio nel
bel mezzo del museo le luci che emette i
suoni e che è in grado di generare piano
piano si affievoliranno fino a spegnersi
ed è proprio in questa fragilità in
questa vulnerabilità esposta a cui non
siamo abituati che forse risiede una
delle grandi speranze che possiamo
avere nel rifondare e il nostro rapporto
con la tecnologia e nella consapevolezza
che i dati non solo possono separare ma
anche unire proprio come è successo
sulle rive di questo fiume e vedete
stiamo usando delle parole strane
rispetto al tema stiamo parlando di
opere d'arte vive stiamo dicendo che la
tecnologia serve ad attuare nuove
ritualità nelle nostre vite quotidiane è
un po strano ma ha un senso noi questa
condizione che stiamo descrivendo nel
nostro centro di ricerca la chiamiamo il
nuovo abitare che è semplicemente la
nostra condizione umana del dell'era
della conoscenza e delle reti in questo
mondo iperconnesso e globalizzato che ci
troviamo ad abitare la nostra stessa
sopravvivenza
almeno sopravvivenza dignitosa
dipende da enormi quantità e qualità di
dati lo abbiamo visto durante la
pandemia in cui i nostri diritti e le
nostre libertà dipendevano esattamente
da enormi quantità e qualità di dati che
decretavano se potevamo andare a scuola
se potevamo uscire se dovevamo stare
chiusi in casa o quant'altro ecco questa
è una trasformazione importante perché i
dati diventano un elemento esistenziale
nella nostra vita non tecnico e poi c'è
anche un altro a cosa da notare è questa
cosa è che tutti gli attori del nostro
ecosistema possono generare ed
esprimersi tramite i dati
noi come esseri umani in genere amo
tantissimi ma anche gli edifici le
foreste gli animali le aziende tutti gli
attori che abbiamo intorno gli oggetti
persino possono generare dati e quindi
questi dati possono diventare noi lo
chiamiamo un common ground un terreno
comune che ci permette di acquisire
tramite la computazione quindi la
elaborazione di dati la possibilità di
trasformare questi dati in cose che sono
più adatte ai nostri sensi come la luce
della grafica e il suono la musica
quindi i dati che possono essere
trasformati in tutte queste cose ci
possono fornire una sensibilità maggiore
verso tutti gli altri attori del nostro
ecosistema
ecco questo è il nuovo abitare e se
siete un po avvezzi al alle discussioni
alle conversazioni che si fanno di
solito quando si parla di dati di enti
licenza artificiale non faticherete ad
accorgervi che sono molto diverse da
questi discorsi che stiamo facendo
serve infatti per attuare questo nuovo
abitare queste nuove alleanze
serve un salto di immaginazione e quindi
serve che l'arte la musica il design in
generale la creatività alla moda entrino
lì dove si fanno le decisioni dove si
stabiliscono le strategie e non
rimangano semplicemente una decorazione